[Musique]
le monde entrer dans une nouvelle ère
grâce à moi
l'humanité va enfin se plier à ma
volonté
on va pousser ça va débloquer non je
vous attendais rien la vie même chercher
champignac le meilleur scientifiques de
la planète
pourquoi ils emmènent vieux bar i télé
petit bouchon on a peur vous rappeler
ses copines avaient bloqué sur cette
fille si toi et non à la casse qui
soutient bougex pipi piron c'est comme
moi n'ont plus cours
te donnerai jamais ma formule non non
non non pour trouver son pinacle
on n'aime pas mais tu peux vous poser
une question et oui qui tient volant et
pas moi c'est quoi vivre sur son sol
tellement paradis dont je t'ai entendu
mais encore raté toi je t'avais dit le
shooter quand il est arrivé rater ça
ah ah
by pass photos
je suis trop bruyant
tu avais pas m'en faire atterrir ce truc
essai
les poissons ça vous dit qu il
c'est pas de ma faute si vous avez les
pieds couleur saumon
[Musique]